hi I'm clairvoyant movie blogger Nixie
er le and I revered YouTube commenter
Brad Evans and we are team Coco's
official Oscar prognosticators here to
give you the inside squeeze on what to
expect on Oscar Tuesday for best actors
my Oscar pick goes to Julia Roberts I'm
not sure if she was eaten in a movie
this year but I don't think that will
hurt her chances because she's always
been box-office gold and you know what
else is gold Oscars for Best Picture my
pick is 1917 it's a great movie that
reminds us how awesome world wars are
hopefully it's win will inspire the
Pentagon to start a new world wars that
someday we'll be able to get Best
Picture to a movie called 2020 all eyes
are on what fashion gadfly Anthony
Hopkins will be wearing most are saying
a suit but I think sir Hawkins will only
be wearing baggy Billabong board shorts
that he stole from a pack Sun and that
the entire Oscars this year is a sting
operation to get him
I'm predict that the Oscars are gonna
give the Lifetime Achievement Award to
the coca-cola freestyle machine the
movie industry is dying and the only
thing keeping people flocking to the
theaters is this wonderful contraption
that's able to mix barks root beer and
Powerade if you're a winner be sure to
thank coca-cola because their perfect
machine is keeping your career going
best celebrity salad dressing Paul
Newman's Newman's Own has been sweeping
this category for decades but this year
I think we're in for an upset my pick
Jacob Tremblay spicy little stinker
sauce Brad Pitt is the favorite to win
Best Supporting Actor and my prediction
is that during his acceptance speech he
is going to invite former flame Jennifer
Aniston onstage and they're going
rekindle their Brangelina romance I tell
you what I think this big win is gonna
act as such an aphrodisiac for Brad Pitt
that he's gonna invite Brangelina back
to his place and make whoopee on her and
hopefully this sweet Whoopi making
session results in some new Brangelina's
for us if Brangelina doesn't get back
together the Oscars I promise I will
quit my job
not as an Oscar ologist my job as a
father we're both gonna go to sleep for
an entire year until they ask us to do
this again